[Music]
we saw smoke come from inside the
station and people were screaming we
hurried to the station that the fire was
spreading it was horrible
[Music]
I'm without makeup I saw dead bodies
with many dead bodies
I saw if it seems flesh on the floor the
train was carrying many people I removed
nearly 20 dead bodies and carried them
to the ambulance all were completely
burned
[Music]
what a lot of PBR I tried to put out
everything in front of me first I used
water then I realized that if he bore
water on wounds they hurt more we
started using fire extinguishers but
that didn't work then we took blankets
which we had in our kiosks and we
started covering people with them during
the incident I ran and saw people
burning in front of my eyes I didn't
know why I was running back and forth
that was the most horrible thing I've
ever seen in my life
people dying right in front of you and
you can't do nothing about it thank God
I did my best and saved somebody thank
God
[Music]
you